okay do you want to play with okay
shout out to my new friend
they said hello to his little friend
that's actually a line that's kind of
funny because cocaine can also cause
erectile dysfunction that's something to
just keep in mind while this is going on
too hey gq i'm dr eric bender i'm a
psychiatrist who specializes in child
adolescent adult and forensic psychiatry
and this is the breakdown
[Music]
first step fight club
for six months
i couldn't sleep i couldn't sleep i
couldn't sleep
with insomnia nothing's real right away
the narrator talks about being sleep
deprived insomnia for six months when
you are sleep deprived
you do not think clearly in fact it's
considered unethical to sleep deprive
someone more than 48 hours in some
places sleep deprivation is considered a
form of torture everything's far away
everything's a copy of a copy of a copy
you can see that quick flash of tyler
durden coming up and he's saying
everything's a copy of a copy of a copy
and you see him kind of sleeping fight
club is i'm guessing purposefully
unclear as to what is going on with the
narrator here you see him have this
hallucination this is very common with
sleep deprivation when you have sleep
deprivation you can first start to get
very confused and then after time you
can have some delusions and some
hallucinations and the hallucinations
and sleep deprivation can be complex you
can actually have auditory and visual
hallucinations you can actually have
distortions even of your own body
sensing that your body is changing and
as we know the narrator looks quite
different from tyler durden so there's
quite a change in
how he appears you can also believe you
are someone else in fact in studies of
sleep-deprived individuals some of them
said i felt like i was another person a
lot of themes in fight club have to do
with
consumerism and
belonging the idea that a club a place
to belong here you have this group of
men fighting each other and beating each
other to a pulp you have to wonder if
they're getting in some nice shots to
the head and does that actually make
people have more delusions or more
hallucinations in the beginning of the
movie after he goes to the group there
is a moment when he cries and then he
sleeps there can be a very cathartic
experience meaning this release of
something that helps you
move on with it in your life it can be a
release of emotions when you cry and it
doesn't surprise me that he would sleep
the data show you actually need to sleep
about 50 of the time you've been
deprived in order to get back to a
baseline
functioning cognitively
and behaviorally the way you were before
he clearly didn't do that and maybe
that's why we actually see tyler durden
more and more present because he's more
and more sleep deprived there was a
study that was done showing
how people that were sleep deprived
responded to certain texts just just
reading text those who were sleep
deprived for about 35 hours looked at
the text and they actually did a scan in
the brain they showed that the
connections between the amygdala where
your emotions are kind of centered in
your brain
and the frontal cortex where you can
actually organize them and keep stable
it doesn't connect the way it should
when your sleep state is actually good
when you're sleep deprived there's not a
connection instead you go into this
fight-or-flight
reaction and fight club or flight i
guess is more appropriate in this case
next up scarface
[Music]
this is tony montana who's become this
cocaine emperor essentially he is so
high that he has missed on the screens
earlier that all these people are
invading his home he's also becoming
more and more paranoid throughout the
movie
when tony's talking to his sister here
it's possible that that's some of the
psychosis he's experiencing that
everything's gonna be fine as he's
talking to his dead sister he's now got
this incredible
drive to kill everybody around him this
is cocaine-induced
psychosis quite possibly or at least the
effects of using cocaine cocaine's a
drug that can make someone feel like
they have more energy it increases the
dopamine in the system by blocking
dopamine from being taken up by the
brain and dopamine is the pleasure
chemical that your brain makes it also
can make you feel
more confident it can make you feel
paranoid and delusional so throughout
the film we've seen tony get more
paranoid here he's pretty delusional
he's going to take down all of these
agents while they're coming into his
house before this you've seen a mountain
of coke on his desk and he's just
snorting it or even like dropping his
head into it so there's definitely some
cocaine on board you want to play with
us
paul's here there is the delusion that
he's going to just take everybody out
himself they said hello to his little
friend that's actually a line that's
kind of funny because cocaine can also
cause erectile dysfunction that's
something to just keep in mind while
this is going on too again violence is
not inherent for people who have mental
illness there are certain situations
where violence can occur we've talked
about when somebody might have a
delusion and they want to protect
themselves and it's an acute psychosis
issue another place where you might have
more violence is actually with
substances and cocaine is one of those
you can get more aggressive so grabbing
a grenade launcher certainly is a sign
of aggression tony's reaction here the
cocaine is is working in a system he's
not feeling like he's doing anything
wrong or out of the ordinary he's also
defending his house cocaine was used as
an anesthetic originally when he gets
shot many times it's interesting that he
doesn't necessarily fall down right away
but stays upright was it that much of an
anesthetic i doubt it but
that was likely more hollywood it does
actually have some anesthetic purposes
we don't use it for that anymore
obviously black swan
here we see nina who's working really
hard and she's not feeling quite herself
suddenly in the mirror it seems like her
movements are not happening in real time
that can illustrate an illusion she
might see something go but
it looks like it's larger than it is or
it looks like somebody that she doesn't
know hallucination would be if it
weren't there to begin with it's not
clear exactly what's happening there's
so many factors contributing to why she
might be experiencing this she has this
overbearing overprotective mother this
competitive frenemy there's some stress
levels that are going up there's also
some hints that she has an eating
disorder and when your brain is not fed
or nourished you don't think clearly so
it's possible that all this is
contributing to how she's seeing the
world around her that nina's seeing her
reflection differently that could be
more of an illusion that she's seeing
her reflection which is there but it
appears distorted i don't know that
there's any particular significance to
the fact that she's seeing herself other
than she's now been really really
focused and obsessive about things and
there does seem to be a level of
obsession that can be almost psychotic
it's it's delusional that you need to do
this or else this is gonna happen you're
gonna lose your part you're gonna not
have friends whatever it is so there can
be a level of anxiety that almost seems
delusional and maybe she's experiencing
that along with seeing these other
things when someone has body dysmorphic
disorder they
see their body differently than it
actually is someone might focus on their
ear think their ear is not formed
correctly and see plastic surgeons and
want to change it and they just don't
see how their body is shaped the way it
actually is if she has some form of this
it would make sense that she's not
seeing how her body looks in the mirror
properly but this looks more to be like
a hallucination or an illusion because
it's doing things differently it's
actually
moving differently if nina is sleep
deprived too from all the work and time
she's putting into her dancing that can
also generate some of these possible
hallucinations and worries and the way
she sees herself shutter island
let's put them at the table andrew
we'll try them off
we'll change their clothes
they'll be our living dolls
here we see dolores having
just committed this horrible crime she's
talking about her kids who are deceased
as if they can be living dolls she has
had a history in the movie of bipolar
disorder that's what they're at least
suggesting in bipolar disorder you can
have psychotic symptoms too you can have
hallucinations and it sounds like she
either had hallucinations or some
delusional beliefs about
killing her children it's not clear
exactly what was going on was was there
a command auditory hallucination that
told her to do this was it delusional
thinking she is really delusional though
and you can see how andrew's responding
here really upset a colleague of mine
had a 14 year old boy who was psychotic
and the boy actually asked him so am i
going to become a serial killer now
that's not what we need to teach people
that because there's mental illness
there's violence there are some states
during which someone with mental illness
could be prone to violence but it's not
because they're prone to being violent
they might be
trying to defend themselves because of a
delusional belief that kind of violence
is actually often most occurring at home
the likelihood of being hurt by someone
who's got a mental illness is
way less than
getting struck by lightning
when dolores says set me free it is
possible that she's letting us know just
how much she's struggling
in her life what andrew ends up doing in
killing her he then ends up in this
forensic setting on shutter island
that's a little unlikely in reality he
knows what he's doing
he knows what he's doing is wrong and
he's even crying about killing her after
crying about the kids he knows what's
going on that means you would not
qualify for
not guilty by reason of insanity defense
that's actually even applied in less
than one percent of the cases and a
small fraction of that even go through
that doesn't mean that someone is
getting off scot-free what that actually
means is someone goes to a forensic
hospital where they're treated for the
mental health issue that was present at
the time of the crime to help them in
some cases that amount of time takes
longer than someone would have served
time in a prison or jail for the crime
they committed what i think happens with
andrew is that he has a a traumatic
reaction he realizes what he's done it's
so heinous to him that he dissociates
meaning he is not in touch with what is
going on in the world he's not touched
with many things and this exercise on
shutter island would be almost a
depersonalization that he's stepped away
and he's this teddy person in this
scenario this would not happen why is he
in a forensic hospital when in fact he
knew what he was doing knew what he was
doing was wrong he'd probably be in
prison the jumping of the camera angle
could possibly represent that now
dolores is recognizing what she's done
so suddenly it shifts from this place
where she's not clear about things or
maybe had some delusional belief to
realizing what happened because that's
when she actually says to
andrew
set me free
split
you kill me
no wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait no no no
don't do that don't do that he can't
handle reality the character in split is
showing signs of what is now called
dissociative identity disorder a former
term was multiple personality disorder
typically someone has had chronic trauma
in their lives early on and has
dissociated meaning they've separated
from that experience because it's too
much to handle emotionally and another
personality develops it's not another
person it's another personality and
alters what the name is for that other
personality develops and these alters
help the individual deal with the trauma
that they've experienced
my name is jade has dr fletcher been
getting our emails this is what we have
to do
as in 1008 when ana de paula suffered
the his most crushing defeat so in this
scene we see
james mcavoy go through
jade and then there's another one and
there's barry
everybody just take a minute and then we
come to the beast the last one that
all the other personalities supposedly
have been helping to keep these girls
captive personalities that are alters
are there to help the host or the person
who has all these alters deal with
trauma they are not going to gather
captives for another one of the
personalities this is not a
weaponization of an individual this is a
way to cope as you watch the changes
from one altar to the next you could see
there's a difference in how they were
speaking that can actually happen the
research that used neuroimaging to look
at the altars showed that the altars
function differently in the brain
regions you can have some that have
different accents you can't have some
that are left-handed some might be
right-handed you can have some that show
physical changes in fact when you look
at the last change here into what seems
to be the beast finally it looks as if
james mcavoy is almost stronger in some
way in order to have a diagnosis of
dissociative identity disorder you need
to have at least one additional alter or
feeling of being possessed you can have
memory lapses and that can often be
believed
to happen as you transition from one
altar to the other how fast somebody
transitions from an altar i think this
is somewhat of a plot driven device to
have this all come down to this moment
in the movie during therapy you work
with a therapist to
ultimately integrate the personalities
but it's not so much about integrating
the personalities as it is about
processing the trauma that someone has
gone through and understanding how this
has affected their life how it's
affected their confidence how it's
affected their sense of what's safe and
secure so you really want to work with
somebody in a gentle way to go through
some of this trauma and
as you deal with that the idea is that
some of these alters and these
personalities get integrated more into
the one host personality this depiction
is highly dramatized you can have up to
100 personalities this
character has 23 the average is 10 from
the literature and some of the
literature suggests the personalities
can start to develop as early as age 5.9
that's realistic in the sense of having
multiple personalities in the one host
the violent piece is not
accurate you're not going to have a
personality that is just out to be
violent again it's going to be more
protective there might be a personality
that has beef with the other
personalities or other people
that are in the person's life but you're
not going to have somebody who's going
to go out and just wreak havoc legally
if someone actually did commit a crime
just because they have dissociative
identity disorder doesn't mean they
would go to a forensic hospital or meet
criteria for not guilty by reason of
insanity defense you look at whether
that alter knew
right and wrong and knew the nature and
quality of what they were doing primal
fear
is aaron stampler capable of murder no
he is not he is far too traumatized to
express normal anger and frustration he
keeps his emotions repressed which is
why he created roy who is capable of
such an objection your honor the idea
that when he's in trouble he calls you
that does fit an idea of if someone were
to have dissociative identity disorder
that a personality would be protective
it's a way of dealing with trauma so it
loosely fits that idea that there's some
protection from the altar what's
not accurate in primal fear
is the way this plays out no further
questions your honor where the hell do
you think you're going excuse me aaron's
on trial and suddenly this roy alter
comes up and threatens someone in the
court the judge ends up ending the trial
mid-jury and saying let's adjudicate
this not guilty by reason of insanity
aaron goes to a forensic hospital in
reality even if it were legally okay to
stop a trial mid-trial and change the
way it's functioning california the
legal statute is do you know what you're
doing or do you know what you're doing
is wrong roy knew what he was doing knew
what he was doing was wrong even at the
end of the movie he reveals that he's
faking the way he's
doing in the movie he wouldn't go to a
forensic hospital they make it so that
it can't be changed in the movie but
again the direction it goes is just
a little off there are actually measures
you can do when you interview someone to
make sure they're not faking this
character's doing what's called
malingering that's presenting as if you
have mental illness faking it
essentially in order to get something
usually what's called a secondary gain
meaning something outside yourself like
food clothing shelter or a different
treatment in this case to not go to
prison and
go somewhere else if the ruling becomes
not guilty by reason of insanity the
individual would go to a forensic
hospital and have their mental health
issue treated malingering does happen
and there are ways to detect whether or
not someone is malingering and that's
very important that's an important role
for a forensic psychiatrist to interview
someone and make sure there's not
evidence suggesting that the person is
feigning symptoms just to get something
the dark knight rises
i told you i was immortal
here batman bruce wayne is
just had his back broken by bane he's
alone so there's a question of is the
solitary confinement so to speak has
that caused him to have some
hallucinations what this actually could
be is delirium delirium is a state where
your thinking is waxing and waning
meaning sometimes it's accurate
sometimes it's not and it can happen
with pain it can happen with infection
it often happens in the hospital in the
icu for patients particularly at night
it can be called sun downing where at
night suddenly somebody's completely
restless tries to rip out all the ivs
that they have maybe rip out foley
catheter and that's part of delirium
it's it's this changing in their
cognition that might be part of what's
going on bruce wayne's getting ideas
about raz al ghul he might be seeing him
hallucinations can occur that's my
thought on why he might be experiencing
this the way he is on the way to sleep
sometimes your thoughts get all strange
they call that hypnagogic hallucinations
where things kind of seem strange and
when you wake up it's called hypnopompic
it's possible if he's delirious where
he's kind of in and out of thinking
clearly maybe his thoughts are all
getting
mixed together in the same way when
you're on a way to sleep and you
sometimes get an idea for something you
could have an idea like this come up
when you're delirious it's just unclear
whether you'd actually remember it or
who knows exactly what's going on in
someone's mind when this occurs it's
also possible that bruce wayne's
experiencing
sensory deprivation
hallucinations meaning that he hasn't
been in touch with anything in this
solitary confinement that he's in the
pain that he's experiencing can also be
contributing to him possibly having
hallucinations pain can be a reason why
people have hallucinations in multiple
settings when they experience that much
of discomfort from pain that can really
cause some psychotic symptoms at times
old boy
[Music]
here we see desu who's been kept in this
room
and not been allowed to get out he
starts to see that there are ants coming
out of his skin and all over his body
that is a visual hallucination meaning
he's seeing something that's not there
it's actually a particular type there's
a name for this there's something called
eckbomb syndrome which is when you
believe that you're infested with
parasites now ants aren't parasites and
i think ants represent something
particularly in this film but the idea
that there's something infesting you
some kind of parasite
is a delusion so that's a delusion
meaning that you believe something
that's not true visual hallucinations
are more common with drugs and substance
use particularly stimulants but there
might be something that is happening
here we don't see
we don't see
what he's being given we know that the
captors in his mind want to take him out
of the room at times and bring him back
they probably do this through drugging
him so this could be a visual
hallucination due to whatever he's being
given another delusion that desu might
be experiencing is qatar syndrome
there's a range of things that someone
with qatar's syndrome can believe but
you can believe you're rotting to death
you can actually believe you're dead and
in the end here we see him dying these
are hallucinations that he's seeing too
so this is a psychotic issue he's having
so at first when you see desu itching
that's actually a term called
formication and again that can be from
drug use you might remember the
chappelle show where he's itching all
over the place after using crack that's
the idea of formication you itch all
over the place and often it's because
you think it's due to things crawling on
your skin when someone is left in
solitary confinement they can develop
hallucinations there are all kinds of
research that has been done in the
correctional population showing even
that after a few days you can have some
kind of hallucinations in solitary
confinement after 15 days there's a
consideration of it not being ethical
and there's some research that suggests
even after a short amount of time you
could have permanent mental health
issues as a result of solitary
confinement hallucinations are things
that aren't really there so you won't
die from a hallucination you could die
if you acted on something because of
delusional thinking or because of
paranoia and you act on something then
you could die it's actually extremely
important to ask patients who are
psychotic about suicide just because
they have psychosis doesn't mean they
also have other symptoms of mental
health issues in about 15 percent of
suicides psychotic thinking or psychotic
belief was involved thanks so much for
watching these clips with me i hope you
learned something until next time